dans un royaume lointain on murmure des
histoires étranges sur maléfique est bel
et bien la méchante fée qui vit au coeur
de la forêt et sur les créatures
fantastiques qui lui obéissent du
puissant arbres guerrier à la lumineuse
fait des eaux en passant par le
gargantuesque dragon de la forêt d'où se
range aux côtés de maléfique pour
combattre ceux qui osent envahir son
royaume
mais aucune créature ne lui ai plus
dévoués que diamal un être humain et
visage j'étais si beau pourquoi
m'avez-vous transformé de la sorte tant
que femme tantôt corbeau pour sa
maîtresse il endosserait tous les
costumes
ces terres sont réellement peuplé de
créatures extraordinaires mais la plus
effrayante de tout est maléfique elle
même avec ses aises imposante et ses
puissants pouvoirs magiques
c'est une force à pitoyable avec
laquelle il faut côté découvrez tous les
secrets de la forêt non maléfique de
disney